foreign
[Music]
[Music]
doing in our front yard our entire world
is in grave danger I want you to come
with me on an expedition
I'm not my father he was the Explorer I
know you were just a kid when he went
missing but now you're all we got Mr
Clay I'm a huge fan thank you [ __ ] your
dad do you think you could Forge his
autograph
where in the world are we
who brought the dog sorry
[Music]
we are clearly in Uncharted Territory
foreign
hello you probably don't understand a
word I'm saying of course I understand
you huh dad dad Grandpa I'm a grandpa
what is this place the cliffs are alive
and the waters dissolve the flesh off
your bones everything down here is
trying to kill us
[Music]
do you mind if I call you splat you just
kind of give me Splat Vibes
I guess I deserve that
Grandpa's awesome he is not awesome you
gave me a machete for my birthday a
classic Jager claimed I was too
I'm loving this family reunion oh come
on we got a world to save
we need you to figure this out otherwise
we're doomed we are doomed wait
seriously no I'm just messing with you
couldn't see that coming
[Music]
all right
[Music]
prepare yourself for a journey beyond
what is possible Walt Disney Animation
Studios proudly presents Strange World a
new Motion Picture event
travel past space and time to a place of
infinite mystery unlike anything you've
ever seen
where in the world are we
life in uh
[Music]
we are in way over our heads
I'm not an Explorer I'm a farmer
[Music]
we need to get out of here
if you want to back out this is the time
you do it
really
oh messing with you come on let's make
history
foreign
[Music]